Hello everyone. Thank you for
coming to this talk today.
This is the final
intern talk by Andrea.
Andrea has been an intern
with us for this summer on
these special internship
projects on spatial audio.
He is a PhD student at
New York University,
and he will be talking about
Blind Room Volume Estimation.
With that, Andrea please.
>> Thank you Anis.
All right thanks
for coming to my talk.
The title for my talk is Towards
Real-time Blind Room
Volume Estimation from
Single Channel Audio Signals
in Noisy Conditions.
The word "Towards"
here is important.
So, let's move to the outline.
So, today I'm going to
give some background and
motivation of why this project
was fought in the first place.
Some previous work and
objectives that we
derived from literature.
Our proposed approach,
and we're going to go
through the data
that we collected,
the features that we
decided to compute,
our prediction model,
and the results.
Then finally, we're
going to discuss
some future works and
improvements that
could be implemented,
some conclusions and discussion.
So, let's start from
the background.
So acoustic parameters,
why do we care about them.
In mixed and augmented reality,
virtual sources are desired to be
perceived as fitting with
the rest of the user
physical space.
So, we want to mix
reality, real sources,
and virtual sources to blend
together in the same
perceptual space.
So this would improve
auditory plausibility,
spatial audio immersion,
spatial audio quality.
So acoustic room tailoring
can be achieved by using
a room impulse response
that is specific to
the spacing questions.
So, we can measure
room impulse responses
and that will describe,
how does the sound behave for
a particular source receiver
position is inside the room.
As you can see from the image,
this is more or less the idea
that mixed reality
wants to achieve.
So, you have a listener
inside an environment
and you want
the virtual sound source
to blend together with
a real sound source.
However, room impulse responses
are very difficult to measure,
they required
technical expertise.
So, scientists have developed
synthesis methods they can use
acoustic parameters to
model an impulse response.
So, as you can see
from this image,
I think most of you are familiar,
but I'm going to just
give a brief overview.
There are impulse
responses made over
the fuse part which is
independent of the location,
the response is
taking within a room.
But the first part, there is
direct sound and
early reflection,
that part is position dependent.
So, going to the use
case of mixed reality,
we may want to create
an adaptive algorithm that can
dynamically adapt to the position
of the user within a space.
So, here we can see
for example a school,
and there's some
HoloLens users that
wants to move around
from an auditorium,
he moves to a corridor,
then he moves to a room,
moves back to an auditorium
and goes around the building.
Each one of these spaces,
they sound very
different acoustically.
So it is necessary to
capture the parameters
that describe the local
acoustic environment
in each one of
these spaces separately.
The challenges of this problem is
that blind estimations
cannot make
assumptions over
the local environment
where somebody is
present at the time.
So, for example, in this
image we can see many people
wearing some sort of
mixed reality device,
and they're surrounded
by noise sources.
There is bubble nodes,
there is ambient noise,
perhaps there's also a fan noise.
They might be
all different devices
where some of them are
multiple microphones,
some of them only
have one microphone,
maybe some of them have cameras.
So we wanted to think about
something which is more
generalizable and simple for each
one of these situations.
So, our approach was to
think of situations to make
something that's
generalizable as possible.
The way we decided to go is for
single channel
audio-based estimations.
Blind estimation means we
have no prior knowledge
of the space,
we have no prior knowledge of
the sources around the listener,
or the geometry of the room.
So, previous work on
acoustic parameters are mostly
focused on two main parameters
called the reverberation time,
T60 or the DRR, the
Direct-to-Reverberant ratio.
There's quite a big body
of literature
about the blind prediction
of these two parameters.
Other parameters have not been as
covered as much as
the T60 and the DRR,
but the T60 is basically
the time it takes for
nucleus response to
decay down by 60dB,
and the DRR is the
Direct-to-Reverberant ratio that
describes the ratio between
the first part and the late part.
More recently,
literature has proposed
a different way to describe
an acoustic environment,
and it does this by
the reverberation fingerprint.
So, the reverberation
fingerprint is no harder than
a frequency-dependent T60 decay
coupled with an initial
power spectrum,
and the room volume.
So at the beginning
of this internship,
we started looking at T60 and
DRR, thinking okay, well,
maybe we can improve what
has been done in the past.
So, these are the results of
the A's Challenge in 2015.
Back at the time,
most methods were signal-based.
There was not much
machine-learning into
spatial audio at the time.
So the best results were
achieved by single
processing methods.
After 2015, the numbers don't
really matter specifically,
but basically octave
spectral-band based algorithms
were the best-performing.
Recently, machine
learning approaches
have improved
this emission of T60.
So, these are the
results from two papers,
one is from Hannes and
another one is another paper
that came out this year.
These are two approaches
that use machine learning
to predict the T60,
and they show that
quite an improvement from
previous method can be achieved.
So, they both outperformed any
of the algorithms in 2015.
So, this was quite
an interesting thing to find
because these approaches are
quite new in spatial audio,
and they are
the first three attempts
but they seem to produce
already considerable
improvements.
So we kept this in mind
as we went forward.
One thing to know that
we took out of this is
also the T60 is
almost the sole problem.
The current literature shows
really good results and
of course it's possible
to improve it,
but we thought that
there is space to try to
compute something else.
The DRR, on the other hand,
it's a parameter that is
source-position dependent.
So, if you estimate the DRR,
you can estimate it for
one particular source,
but that doesn't tell you
much about other sources that
you want to render within
the local environment.
So, instead we decided
to choose a different parameter
and that was room volume.
So why room volume?
Room volume as a parameter,
as an acoustic parameter,
can serve as a proxy to
obtain other parameters.
So, for example,
the critical distance can
be described by a formula
that includes volume.
Also the initial power
spectrum that we saw
from the energy decay release,
which was the T62 decay,
the initial power spectrum
can be adapted using
a ratio of a reference
volume and a local volume.
That work has been also discussed
during the AVA conference
for those of you that were there.
So it seems to be
something that right
now people are starting
to think about,
but there is
very little amount of
literature about
the prediction of room volume.
So, we decided that this
might be a good opportunity
to try something new,
and try to to see
what's possible to
do using similar approaches
that are being used
recently for T60.
One question that we
had the beginning,
is whether we can
hear volume at all.
So, these audio examples,
they show dry signal
convolved with
free impulse responses from
three different
rooms where the T60
was the same but the volume
was very different.
So, all the three examples,
they have T60 time
of about one second,
but the rooms where
they were recorded,
they were all different sizes.
So, the first room was
only 100 cubic meters,
second was 900, and the third
was 8,000 cubic meters.
So, I've tried to
play the signals.
The problem is that they're
going to go through speakers,
so we're going to hear
to volume this room
on top of the volume of
the room it was recorded.
This is the original signal
which was provided
by Professor Purkey.
This is the small room.
This is the median room.
This is the big room.
Right. So, one of them,
there's more room is clearly
different to their sound.
Perhaps some absorption
coloration is involved there too.
The medium and the
big, they're little.
They sound more
similar in this space,
but if you listen to them
through head phones,
you can notice something
different in the low frequencies.
I'll just play them once more.
So original, small room,
medium room, and big
room. All right.
So, that we don't know.
I'm going to get to
that point later.
>> Apparently not,
if you go back and
see the form of
a critical distance.
>> Yeah, that's one of
the challenges. We don't know.
The data that we collected is
mostly from data sets who
do not provide that information.
So, this is one case example,
but we'll produce more.
>> Why is that, the
T60 is the same,
so they have a similar
perceptual quality.
The first thing you notice about
the room is how
reverberant is it.
They are similarly reverberant,
but the volume is different.
So, their properties are
obviously different
because they have
different volumes
but the same became.
>> Fine.
>> But the question is,
can you hear a difference
just based on
that one parameter changes,
which is the volume?
>> Right. So, just by
listening to these examples,
we were thinking about
what possible representations
could capture this information,
and we're going to get back
to these in later slides.
So, previous work about
blind volume estimation.
There's not as much literature
as 4060 or DRR.
It's been treated
as a side problem,
but recently, it's
been brought up again.
In 2012, there was
a paper about rooming
identification using
Gaussian Mixture
Models and MFCCs.
The problem with that paper
is that this use
the same rooms in the training
and the test set.
That as we can see later on,
makes a big difference
in your results.
They somehow achieve
23 percent equal
error rate, I think.
But the way they
divided floor room,
sorry, impulse response
location within the room.
But having the same
room in both sets,
it's not really telling
you much, I think.
>> What is GLMM?
>> I think Gaussian
Mixture Model.
I think that is an M
there for some reason.
I got to check that.
Another paper by Shabtai
used an abrupt speech
detector in speech signals,
to detect the end of
a sentence of word,
and from that moment in time,
treat whatever comes after,
as if it were an
impulse response.
So, whenever a word was
uttered, the end of the word,
especially after
a very sharp consonants
could be treated as if that
was the impulse response.
By selecting that time frame,
they would try to
estimate the volume,
also using Gaussian
Mixture Models.
But that paper only looked
at clean conditions,
so free from noise.
That matter was also brought
up again in a recent paper,
where they implemented
the same method,
and they trained it for
a regression model.
But they only tested
this method on
a ISM data, so
image-source model.
So, the image source
model creates
a very clean synthesize
impulse response,
which works well for shoe box
rooms, rectangular rooms,
but on the other hand,
is not really representative
of real situations.
So, even there, they
trained something that works
in a theoretical model,
but there was no test
on actual rules.
So, this left quite
a big space for us to try to
come up with a regression model
that could try to estimate
volume from anytime
situation. Yes.
>> So, we have
a source somewhere in
the room, and a microphone.
We have no idea of
where the source is,
where the microphone is, and we
want to estimate the volume.
>> Yes. So, that's
the highest level of blindness
that you can achieve.
You don't know where you are.
You don't know where
the sources is.
How many sources
there are? If there's
noise, if there's no noise?
We wanted to start with
the least amount of
assumptions as possible.
Then, of course,
future work and start
making side assumptions and
try to see semi-blind methods.
We're going to get that, too.
So, our proposed approach
is to detect room volume blindly
from signals using
a convolutional neural network
and form a frame.
The problem is a
regression problem.
So, we aim to
simulate a variety of
noisy environment containing
reverberant speech
within the environment,
and represent as much range
of room size as possible,
and as much real impulse
response data as possible.
So, their impulse response
are used to simulate,
sorry, the noisy environments.
So, we thought about
training a network
from short single channel
audio recordings,
so four seconds long,
using different SNR levels.
So, we simulated different ratios
between the noise and the
speech, the reverberant speech.
The main goal was to
evaluate the results,
to gain insights
into the problem,
and try to move
forward from there.
The four second extract is
also relevant for
real-time estimation.
So, although it's not
exactly real time,
a four second chunk of audio
is fairly fast to evaluate.
That also part of the
requirements so mixed reality,
as somebody moves
around the building.
So, this is the pipeline
that we set in place.
I'm going to talk
about each one of
these steps: we the
collected data;
we synthesize also some data;
then we went on with
the data augmentation;
simulated the noisy rooms;
made our sets, our training,
and development, and
evaluations sets;
we proceed to feature extraction;
we train model; we
evaluated the model;
and then that would inform us on
how did the feature
perform in the model,
and then go back to
extract more features,
or change some parameters.
All right, so data collection.
This was definitely
the most time-consuming part
of the internship,
where several weeks
were spent into
retrieving online data sets,
public data sets, and format them
into something that could
be given to a network.
So, we found 11 public room
impulse response data sets
and two internal data sets.
We only were interested in rooms
for which we add room
volume information.
So, this proved a challenge,
just the time-consuming
challenge to prune each data
set from the entries which did
not have that information.
We had to do some custom
information retrieval
to associate that
information correctly,
clean up the inconsistencies,
parse into a single file.
Boring work but time-consuming.
But at the end of
the data collection,
we ended up with 84 unique rooms.
As you can see, they all
come from different places,
and they were sampled at
different sampling frequencies.
For some reason, one shows
a sampling frequency
of 12.780 kilohertz.
It's kind of odd,
but it's from 1993.
It's a old data set,
so maybe the standards
were not as set as now.
We resampled all this data,
216 kilohertz,
I believe, which is good
enough for speech signals.
So, these are some stats about
the rules that we obtained.
So, the first graph shows
how many unique rooms per
dataset we were able to extract.
The second plot shows
the room volume distribution
on a logarithmic scale.
So, the logarithmic scale,
once we represent
the fact that differences
between small rooms should
be treated differently,
that the same difference
in a larger scale.
So, for example, a room that
is 20 cubic meters can be
sound very different from room
that is 40 cubic meters by
a room that is
2,020 cubic meters,
probably does not sound
very different than
a room that is
2,040 cubic meters.
So, that's why we're representing
the distribution on
a logarithmic scale.
As you can see,
the main problem there
is that we add
a gap in the middle
about available room volumes
in our dataset,
which we fixed a little bit
through data simulation,
and tried to later on, although
a part of the gap still remained.
The last graph on the right,
is just a histogram of the
repetitions or takes per room.
So, each one of these datasets
took different,
they're all different in terms
of how many positions
did they record,
what speakers are
keeping did they use.
Some datasets have maybe
hundreds of takes
inside a single room,
and some are dataset are
only one take inside a room.
So, as a result
the final distribution of
how many input response we have,
is plotted on the graph
on the right.
There is quite a bias towards
these either small rooms,
office sides kind of
room or very large rooms
because quite a few concert halls
in some of the datasets.
Moving on. Then, we decided
to cap the representation to
50 takes per unique room.
So, each unique room was
represented a maximum
of 50 times.
So, simulated data, so Anis
managed together with Nikush
to simulate 50 rooms using
randomly created polygons,
which were shaped in
a way to avoid very
regular rectangular rooms.
So, these irregular polygons
create more realistic geometries,
and the simulation was set up for
100 random receiver position
inside this model,
and Triton was used to simulate
impulse responses for a range of
volumes from 60 to more or
less 3,000 cubic meters.
The results of these models
are band limited
to two kilohertz,
due to the way Triton
works right now.
This data was used to
make a parallel dataset
where we could compare
the effect of adding
simulator rooms against not
having simulator rooms.
>> In train.
>> In train. Yes.
No simulated data
was put into the test
set, or in the train set.
Right. So, once our data
collection was completed,
we moved on to
the corpus creation.
So, this is, if you're familiar
with the ACE challenge,
this is pretty much
the same setup where
room impulse response
two roomy push responses
belonging to the same
room were taken,
and one was convolved with
a speech extract,
randomly chosen,
and the other one was convolved
with either babble noise
or ambit noise.
An SNR was chosen between
four different levels, zero dB,
plus 10 dB, plus
20 dB, an infinite,
meaning that no noise was
included in some examples.
The signals were added together,
and then it was split
into four-second windows.
>> There's still the
speech corpus, you use it,
[inaudible] the circleness
and that precludes speech.
There are 40s to 60 degrees,
60 is the studio recordings.
>> Yeah. Yes. So, infinite is
actually in relationship
to the noise that we add,
not to the noise that was
already in the speech actually.
>> Why did you convolve
the noise with
the room pulse response.
>> So, to make
the noise belong to the same
room as the speech signal.
>> Let me ask, just the
signal direction and noise
was in the room
[inaudible] weird.
>> Yeah. That's like you
place loudspeaker in a room,
then you play that noise.
>> Yeah. I guess it's a way
to just setup the problem
from a single
channel perspective,
yes, I you see what you mean,
but having a, yeah.
In the end everything
was single channels,
so it's to try to come up
with a simple model for now.
>> I guess one aspect,
which is a little bit,
a very little bit deeper in
the ACE challenge setup is
that the ACE challenge
was recorded.
On Ace challenge
the corpus must generate
by recording actual noise
in a real room,
and then mixing it into signal.
What we were trying
to do is generate
training data that would
simulate that somewhat,
but the ambient noise that was in
this real recordings isn't
just some fan noise somewhere.
When I listened to it at least,
I heard that there is
somebody walking down
the corridor because
this was a public space,
so they just recorded
whatever was happening.
So, somebody is walking
down a corridor,
you can hear elevator panes,
you can hear
a door slam somewhere.
So, you have some transient
components in ambient noise,
and so the idea was that
we generate something
that's similar to that type
of ambient noise,
but once you have
these transients in your signal,
you should convolve it with
a impulse response
from the same room,
otherwise you have an echoic
noise mixed into the room.
>> [inaudible] , 60 of the room,
where the noise you're
being recorded in
quantity to the noise.
>> Yeah. The noise was similar.
So, what we did is we had
shaped colored noise,
Gaussian noise, call it Gaussian
noise where the color spectrum
is derived from some of
the noise recording.
>> So, it's a dry noise.
>> Dry noise. Then, added to that
some an echoic random
impulsive sounds
like office equipment,
stuff for footsteps,
things like that.
Then, take that, and
convolve it with the
impulse response,
so that its transient components
are convolved with this.
>> This [inaudible].
>> Yeah.
>> It's a compromise,
but the thing is
some of the datasets only
had one impulse response,
and some did have two,
but we couldn't afford to
discard things just because.
When there were more impulse
responses available,
we used more than just
one to generate noise
that we used up to four,
but not many of those recordings
have more than four or
five impulse responses.
So, it's compromised.
>> So, after this process,
we ended up with a big corpus
of data that we needed to split.
So, we decided to
split the development
and evaluation set
using unique Room IDs.
So, by keeping track of
the room where every
single belong to,
we managed to separate
based on that,
the training set
from the test set,
so that we make sure that
the rooms present in
the test set do not appear at
all in the training stage.
So, the tests comprises the
whole ACE challenge datasets,
which is good to
make resource more
comparable with
previous ACE based papers.
The train and
validation ratios in
the development set were
set to 90 and 10 percent,
and we add two parallel sets
with and without
the Triton simulations.
As I said, each room was
represent a maximum of
50 times, we randomize.
If a room, for example,
had 100 positions, we
randomly chose 50 of them.
It was not an ordered pick.
All right, so features.
Looking at features, something we
did recently is to look
at the low frequency FFT.
So, when Bill arrived,
we talked a little bit
about what might
happen in the modes.
So, the geometry room
would affect
the frequency and the intensity
of the modes of a room.
So, we'll try to see
whether that was
easily capturable by
simple FFT processing.
So, just by looking at
the low-frequency FFT
from 0-500 hertz,
these are the same rooms
that we listen to
audio example from,
and it can already be seen
that a small room compared
to the larger rooms,
first of all, has less,
very low frequency content.
But at the same time,
an interesting thing to look is
the presence of notches
and the distance
between the notches.
So, in the smaller room,
the way the frequency or
the frequency magnitude response
has larger periods compared
to the bigger rooms.
So, this is something
that could be
captured, for example,
by cepstrum, which is
the last plot on the right,
which is trying to capture how
frequently these
notches are and how
spaced apart they
are represented.
>> In general,
the cepstrum gives you
the speed, the spectrum changes.
>> Yeah.
>> It most probably
will not contain
much information about the dips.
>> Right, but if
this spectrum changes fast,
then I would expect more dips,
that to correlate with
the presence of
bigger or more dips.
>> Of course, there's
peaks also, right?
>> Yeah.
>> When there's more dips,
there's also more peaks?
>> Exactly. Peaks and dips.
So, that was part
of some of the features
that we wanted to look at.
In the graph in the middle
just show some sorted
FFT to see what
is essentially the energy
in the low frequency bands.
You can see that the small
room in blue here,
this x-axis doesn't mean
much because this
is all resorted.
But so you can see
a clear difference between
a small room room
and larger rooms,
but in this case, from
the middle to the
large has not much
of a difference.
>> So, it's a sorted FFT.
So, what this is really
showing I guess is
a smaller number of
frequency bands that come
from most of the energy on
the blue curve, for example?
>> Yeah.
>> I see.
>> Again, what is sorted FFT?
>> So, basically, we
take this thing and
we sort it for higher
values to lower values,
and these can tell you if there
are many modes in a room,
this curve will be flatter
and start earlier,
and this will result.
It's easier to see when
you plot it that way.
>> That's not the frequency axis?
>> Yes.
>> It's not a frequency axis.
That's a typo. Yeah.
>> Number of-
>> Yeah. Don't worry.
>> Number of make?
>> Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
>> Okay.
>> One idea here, we're supposed
to look at the slope of
the curve that ends of bigger
step or bigger the room,
that flatter is
the response, and actually,
it's seen that the orange curve
is flatter than the others,
but it's quite
small change difference.
>> So, technically,
you can do statistics
over the frequency axis,
like minimum, maximum,
mean, variance?
>> Yes.
>> If you can go even a
second towards
the statistics there.
>> Definitely. Yeah, there is
some ground to work on that.
Later on, we speak
more about features.
The other main thing
that we wanted to look
at is time-frequency
representations.
So, these are two
different representation.
One is the Gammatone Filterbank.
If I'm correct, with
ERB center frequencies,
and the second plot is MFCCs.
So, those are two
different ways that are
used in neural networks to
represent audio signals.
In this case, there are
different resolutions,
but the idea is,
if you have a very
refine time resolution
and not as refined
the frequency resolution,
although that can be changed,
you can probably capture how
each frequency channel
decays through time.
That could hold
some good information about
these modes or just a
frequency behavior in a room.
So, actually,
something to clarify,
the previous slide, this
is from impulse responses.
These are FFTs from
impulse responses,
and these are a time
frequency representation
for our speech signals.
All right, so we
decided to combine
all these features
in what we call
the Feature Stack.
We basically put together
these representation using
Gammatone Filterbank,
FFT, the sorted FFT,
the cepstrum,
an envelope follower
and a lowpass time domain.
>> [inaudible]?
>> So, that was
just the result of
the Gammatone Filterbank applied
with the resolution
that we wished.
So, we've a four seconds
speech signal.
We add I think 64 bins,
time bins of resolution
with 32 bins of hop-size.
This resulted in
1991 time Instances.
So, everything was tailored
to be just the same size,
so that it can fit together
into a single network.
All right, so prediction model.
We started off from
what was already implemented
for the T60 problem.
So, this is from the paper
from Hannes and Ivan, where six-
Linear convolutional
neural network,
followed by a dropper layer,
and fully connected
layer will result into
the neural network
that actually produce
improved results from
the AC challenge.
So, we decided to start from
here and then work our way into
modifications to see what
yielded the best results.
So, by not being
a machine-learning expert it
was a good place to start
and further explore.
So, this was tailored for
a Gammatone ERB filter bank,
middle 21 filters and
four second window,
so that's also why we choose
four second windows to be
able to just reuse
this network easily.
This is a different network
that we adapted for the stack.
So, to fit these combination
of features together
with this network,
we just modified the layers
to result into
four convolutional layer
followed by a dropout and
two fully connected layers
which will produce no linear
combinations of your output.
>> And the output is just a
room volume in cubic meters?
>> Yes, there is a logarithm
of the room volume.
So, everything we decide to
express as log. So, yes.
Moving on to results,
these results are very fresh They
just came yesterday.
Out of the oven.
>> Guys prepared it today.
>> Today, this morning, yes?
Alright. So, the first thing
that we did is to train the model
just on room impulse responses
not the speech signals,
because the intuition is
we can see just on
normal impulse responses,
whether some features perform
better than others and
should be technically
an easier problem
than speech signals.
So, we found out that
generally in most cases,
first of all having the triton
data inside our set would
improve slightly the results
in almost all situations.
The Gammatone filter bank
perform the best.
The MFCCs perform really
bad for some reason,
but we didn't play too
much with these parameters
and settings.
The error metrics that we're
looking at in this table is
the mean square error,
the correlation factor,
and what has been called
the mean multiple or
average multiple,
which came as a metric,
it's a way to say
how many times are we far
from the real volume.
So, for example if
is 6.4 with 6.4
times either bigger or
smaller than the real
volumes on average.
Within the test set. So,
that metric is the mean,
taking the mean as
the absolute of
the logarithm of
the volume error.
>> Say 5.2 mean mean might
define 5.2 means what?
>> Means that on
average our result is
within 5.2 times bigger
or smaller than
the actual room volume.
>> So if it's a thousand
it could be anywhere,
it could 205000.
>> Okay.
>> Speaking from
the first two lines,
does it means that
if you just use
Gammatone filters you
get the best results,
better even then
the stock futures?
>> That was true for the real,
for the room impulse responses
for some reason,
but as we seen in
the next slide it do
not show up in the speech signal.
But y, es it's
an interesting result
that we see actually
Vile had a theory
this morning that's saying
that septum did not,
I forgot materialize.
>> [inaudible] middle frequency.
>> Yes.
>> It has very poor resolution,
low frequencies and the rooms are
low frequencies so just, yes.
>> So, moving on to
the speech signals,
these came in the night.
These are, I'm going to
first present the most
interesting results then
we can go deeper if
people are interested in
knowing all the cases.
But, in this case
these are the results
on by using the oldest stack
of features that
I showed earlier,
on the two parallel sets
we found we felt triton,
and you can see that the results
are slightly better when
the simulated data is
included in the training set.
We obtained a mean
square error of between
0.4 into 0.6, correlation of 0.8.
These are, these
use the model with
the two fully connected layers
after four convolutional layers.
Going further we experimented
with different settings
within the networks.
So these are actually the two
best-performing situations,
by the rating just
sound the layers,
we obtained an average
multiple error of 2.9.
So, this means we are 2.9
times of the real
volume estimation.
So, you can see there's quite,
already from the graph it is
quite a nice division between
the small rooms and
the bigger rooms,
there in the test set.
These small rooms they are
harder to distinguish from
like refined the changes
but at least you can get
a nice separation of
small medium and large.
>> What's the ideal reason
to do images diagonal?
>> Diagonal will be ideal yes.
>> Yes it's a confusion matrix,
chopped off the x axis
is true log of
the volume versus estimated.
You can see nine vertical bars
because we had nine unique rooms
in the test set,
seven from this Ace challenge
and then two that we
took from the databases.
>> So was, unless I
misunderstood the previous line
versus the comparison
between the two.
Seems like the error rate
is lower here.
>> Yes.
>> This is the harder problem.
>> Okay.
>> There are some issues
maybe with the,
so we tried to use
the same framework for
generating the noise signals
as was used in the Ace challenge,
but we applied that to noise
in fine impulse responses,
and that's not what
the Ace challenge was meant for.
So, it looks like the
impulse response says,
"There's very little energy in
your signal which is
just an impulse response,
so I'm going to keep
my noise level very low,
and some." I don't know.
>> Those transients you put
in, impulsive transients,
they give you
a very good estimate of
the impulse response, can verify.
So, instead of the
speech that might be
logging onto the
other loud transient-
>> [inaudible] loads.
>> Yes the noise could.
>> That is also-.
>> It could actually give
useful information to this.
>> Yes. Definitely
it was best with.
>> Yes,.
>> The impulse response.
>> The previous case you
just had a impulse
response a signal.
>> Yes.
>> So, here your
certain more data.
>> Actually the data I
think it's the same.
>> [inaudible] a lot
of things right.
>>Those first seconds.
>> Yes, you get
more data. [inaudible]
>> And what was the SNR?
>>This is [inaudible]
>> All the SNRs.
>> There it is now.
>> Yes. Just because it's so,
it's all it's from zero plus
10 plus 20 and infinite,
which means this to
the all recording SNR.
>> Actually it's a little worse,
it's like close mic.
The actual speech signals
were not very low as,
not very high, sorry.
One thing we didn't do here is,
we should probably do
that for the papers is
use the actual Ace
evaluation set.
So, now we've used these rooms
that they recorded,
those actual impulse responses
that don't appear in
our training set,
but we generated
our own speech signals
and our own noisy speech signals.
But, they have recorded those in
a real room with real noise.
So, we should use that instead.
So, whatever transients were
in there we get we
take advantage of,
if there are no transients then,
because now we probably,
the results are probably
a little bit worse because there
will be fewer transient,
there'll be fewer transients I
imagine in a real imagination
set than what we have here,
because we generated them
randomly so we can just
put these whatever
bits and bolts.
But that's something we'll have
to do for the paper maybe.
>> Yes.
>> It also makes it
easier to record use,
you can just say I've used
exactly that same dataset,
I've just applied this model
to estimate the volume.
>> Yes so, I'm
not going to go through
this slide very much,
but if you want to
discuss these later,
I'll happily bring it up.
You can see, just to
explain how these plots
should be read intuitively,
this is really bad.
This is the MFCCs you can
see that if everything
is aligned is no,
they're not relying on slope
that we wanted to lie.
If it's not in
these slide or different slide
I'll bring it up later.
We have an example where
the training data leaked
into the test set
for some reason,
and then you have
this amazing prediction.
This told us as how
much it's important to
keep room separate.
Other situation, so
the top graphs they're all
different combinations
or small modifications
of the network that I showed
in the previous slide.
The error is more
or less similar,
it gets worse once
you take single
features one at a time.
Yes.
>> So, there was a bug where
training data linked
into the test data,
but not in the sense that
the same data was there.
It was just the
same room and yet,
in both places and
that was enough to
get you really nice results.
Even though you use
different impulse responses.
So, it was different
impulse response,
a different speech signal,
a different noise signal,
but the same room in two places,
and that's another prior
work has done that
and they assume that while
they're separate location so,
they're independent but
they're really probably.
>> I'm actually going
to show it right now.
>> Oh, sorry.
>> Here you are. So, this is
the result when
you have a button,
when the same room linked
into the test set.
You have these amazing 1.6
time within the real volume.
Mean square error of
0.1, correlation of one.
So, this is too good to be true.
>> Yeah.
>> Of course, when you
start from this one
because you have to
bump first, right?
So, you get that one
thing. "Oh, we are
done," then you
realized, "Oh, no.".
>> Yeah.
>> So, I don't think
it will qualify
as a true blind estimation
in that case.
All right, so going back
to where we left off.
Okay, so Future work,
Discussions, and Conclusions.
So, there's many areas of
improvement that we
can think about.
So, the first thing
that we can think of is
whether truly blind
estimation room volume
is necessarily the way to go.
I think if you approach
the problem from a device
specific perspective,
you can come up with
semi-blind approaches
and make assumptions
on some of the room
environment and resources,
by taking advantage of
other sensors present
on your device.
For example, you can use
beam forming on the talker
to have a reference,
so you can compare that reference
to other incoming signals,
make some type of
multi-channel correlation
feature extraction,
you could think about tracking
moving sources and see
how the changes for
space maybe by correlating
that with camera image.
Some depth sensors
in devices can give
you already some kind
of a local measure
on what's around you.
So, this is all food
for thought for more precise
and tailored solutions.
Data collection can be
improved by having
more data, of course.
There was the gap that
I showed earlier.
Perhaps, if we covered
the distribution,
the more evenly the resource
could get better.
This pipeline could be re-used
potentially for
other parameters such as DRR,
T60, in frequency bands,
or the wet level that we
discussed in
the previous meetings.
These will require the data
to be better tailored
for the task.
This is the actually
a different way
to see our current situation.
These are all our 84 real rooms
and this is the volume
in log scale.
Every time you see a jump,
it's data that is missing,
It's something we don't
have a room covering
these spanning what's in between.
So, it will be nice for this
to be as flat as possible.
So, Feature Extraction.
There's a lot of features that
we could explore and look better,
for example the phase spectrum
we talked about,
also like having some kind
of spectrogram of
how does the incoming
phase behaves,
some echo density profiles,
multi-channel features.
We're still not
entirely clear how
the room information
can be isolated
from other factors,
because of course,
you have absorption rates,
you have different degrees
of noisy environments.
Our noisy environments
in the end of the day,
they're kind of a
similar settings.
So, you don't have like
multiple noise sources
at different distances,
maybe if you had one just next to
your microphone, then
everything breaks.
So, this information is
not really available in
literature right now and it's
something that should be
more explored by having
simple experiments.
The Network Model.
So, I did not talk about
this very much earlier,
but having a stacked
features with
different unrelated features that
should not be convolve together,
meant that all our
convolution happening
in one dimension and
not in two dimensions.
So, maybe perhaps there could be
some kind of hybrid network that
could perform a 2D convolution
just on the gammatone part,
and the 1D on the others.
I don't know whether
that's possible or not.
Too much experience with
this sort of problem but
it's something to look into.
Maybe the loss function
can be changed
within the network,
to include some form of
perceptual tolerance of
how bad should the estimator
labeled B compared
to the real volume.
So, we don't know yet what's
our tolerance and how
important it is that we are
close to the real value.
Of course, we can always
explore and change
some of the settings
within our current models.
So, Further Discussion
is of course,
how accurate do we need to be
in estimating room volumes.
There's been no perceptual
studies that looked at
the room volume
discrimination, GNDs.
Well, there has been some
studies for discrimination in
terms of classification but
not in terms of regression.
So, for example, what if we
have a room with
the same absorption coefficient
but different sizes,
what is the GND that we can
discriminate the size
of this room.
This lack of a dataset table
to isolate this parameter from
other elements right now.
So, this will be a good place
to research to try to
understand how important is
perceptually the estimation
of the room volume.
If it's used to just
compute all your parameters
then some correlation
should be drawn
between the parameters
estimated using the volume,
using the estimated volume,
and other forms of estimating
the same parameter.
So, that could tell you
whether it's worth to
use volume as a proxy
for, for example,
the critical distance
or just rethink
the whole thing and just try
to estimate
the critical distance.
So, the other question
is should this
be in the first place
and audio problem?
Well, we know that the audience
more generalizable
for different types of
situations and devices,
not just for
Mixed Reality headsets
but computers,
laptops, telephones,
all sorts of technological device
that possesses a microphone.
Computer vision can, of course,
help to estimate or
cross-validate
the room size estimation.
This is just an image
from then where you
depth dataset that
is something that
just throw an idea
of how image could
help labeling the size of a room.
However, then you start
introducing assumptions
and you still have to fight with
the limitations of
actual technology,
like depth cameras maybe
don't go very far.
There are visual obstacles
might be in your room,
there's another degree of error
that you will have
to account for.
Something that has been,
somebody once explained
me this idea that,
if you could have
just cloud server with
the room size information of
all sorts of places
that being cataloged,
they're ready by
engineers and then you
just download your
impulse response or your device,
this could be
a different way to go.
But going through
the audio approach was our goal.
So, the conclusions
that we can draw from
this internship is
that blind room volume
estimation is a hard problem,
a good solution has not been yet
found but some insights
were gained.
Multiple feature
representations seem to bring
better results than just a
single time frequency
representation.
Adding simulating data did
improve accuracy and reduce
the average multiple
distance error.
So, this also as
a future outlook,
having more tritone data
or having maybe
the future [inaudible]
when maybe in Adam work is
implemented together could even
bring more accurate simulations
to improve our dataset.
Still some work at,
but to our knowledge,
this is the first
regression model
for the blind estimation
of room volume.
So, there was no baseline
to compare against,
and there's like a big space
to move in sideways.
So, that's something positive.
Similar framework as
the ACE challenge
makes the resource
more comparable for
future attempts and
more for literature,
and the community is a
little more attractive.
That will be all. Thanks a lot.
Thanks a lot to Annes
because he helped me inside
and outside of the lab.
Thanks to all the group. I had
a really great time to be
here this summer.
Thanks to the interns.
Thanks to Vina, for
visiting us and I
hope our interactions will
continue in
the future. Thank you.
>> Thanks for
the nice presentation.
One comment on the features.
It was one of the last slides
where you mentioned
echo density would be
in a good feature.
So, I think this is what mainly
characterizes
the ideal room volume
because it showed that you can
have the same reverberation time,
but different room volumes.
In a large room, you will have
a much less density effect
that wasn't in a small room.
So, but I think you can
also determine this from
the frequency response because
you have more room also,
more dips and if you have
a higher echo density.
So, this is probably
the strongest feature
that you can use.
As idea for future works
would be probably,
so we saw you can
somehow estimate the
reverberation time.
So, it would probably
make sense to
jointly estimate reverberation
time and room volume.
Then, could go maybe even
further and also just to have
three or four outputs
to even then estimate
the DRR or probably
the source distance.
But, you got probably
three, four parameters.
If you can manage
them all together,
then probably you have
also less confusions
between room volume and
reverberation time,
or something like this,
and would really give
a nice characterization
of the acoustic things.
It would be a nice thing,
if that would be possible.
>> Maybe one comment
on the echo density.
Unfortunately, we can't calculate
that from speech signals.
So, for impulse responses,
that would be great, but
not for speech signal.
>> Yeah, but you don't need to
calculate specifically
the echo density.
But, for example,
you can see this
in the frequency response
of the impulse response,
and we'll have more dips
and more modes if we
go higher density.
>> Yes. Maybe to turn
the question around.
Maybe echo density
could be one of
the outputs of the model.
>> Yeah, for example.
Yeah. No doubt.
>> So, in general, this is
called multi-skill training.
Can not be forced your network
to estimate stuff,
which you may not even need.
This helps the network
to train better.
So, I guess having
additional reverberation
parameters on the output can
improve the room volume
itself even if you
don't use the others.
>> Or really the idea
of idea of looking
at 500 first hertz or
lowest hertz and taking
the [inaudible] ,
like what you said,
the echo density breaks
or how do those echos come in,
they kind of changed step.
There's the response, then
you see it in that cepstrum.
>> As if they are low-hanging
fruit to implement.
Just try and make,
even just try on
impulse responses and see whether
we should follow
this idea further.
>> So, average cepstrum may
not be that much useful,
but you should plot
the magnitude of
this function of the time.
So, cepstrum is against time.
The frame, it may give
some information.
>> Yeah. Speech signals
definitely will be
better than just
testing those cepstrum.
These are on impulses response.
So, maybe it's okay
to average it on
impulse response, but, yeah.
>> It was classic application of
this cepstrum analysis
at least in
the speech frontend is you do
averaging across the time,
which presumably ease
the cepstrum filter
and you subtract it,
and what's left is the pure Sigma
means removing the
impulse response
between the source
and the microphone,
assuming that the speech has
basically a zero
average cepstrum,
and then the only thing remains
is the impulse response.
That mean can be
eventually useful
because this is in general
the cepstrum of the
impulse response.
>> There was a question online.
>> Yeah.
>> I think already
touched the link,
but I figure that to pass to you.
It's from John Altrich.
It says if they use case that
involves augmented reality,
can we not make use
of geometric info,
that headset is likely
already calculating for
space tracking and
whether we still
need to hear recording in
the computer and
directly come play it,
or we just look into supplementary
[inaudible] resource?
>> Right. So, we
touched this earlier,
but we wanted to generalize
on something that
does not make assumptions about
the capability of
a specific device.
I mean, me personally, I don't
know much about how would
such device like a camera,
for example, perform
interesting meeting volume
if you have obstacles around you,
or if you're facing a wall.
You still have
similar types of problems
that might occlude your vision.
So, it makes sense
that we want to try
an audio-only situation.
Cool.
>> All right. No more questions?
>> All right. Thanks a lot.